Today we'll talk about how to make
machines see computer vision and we will
present thank you.
Whoever said yes,
and today we will present a competition
that unlike deep traffic which is
designed to explore ideas,
teach you about concepts so deeper,
deeper enforcement learning SegFuse,
the deep dynamic driving scene
segmentation,
competition that are present today is at
the very cutting edge.
Whoever does well in this competition is
likely to produce a publication or ideas
that would lead the world in the area of
perception,
perhaps together with the people running
this class,
perhaps in your own.
I encourage you to do so even more cast
today.
Computer Vision today as it stands is
deep learning majority of the successes
in how we interpret form
representations,
understand images and videos utilize to
a significant degree and you're on that
works.
The very ideas we've been talking about
that applies for supervised,
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
and for the supervised case is the focus
of today.
The process is the same.
The data is essential.
There's annotated data where the human
provides the labels that serves as the
ground truth and the training process.
Then the neural network goes through
that data,
learning to map from the raw sensory
input to the ground truth labels and
then generalize or the testing data set
and the kind of raw senses we're dealing
with are numbers.
I'll say this again and again that for
human vision for us here,
we take for granted this particular
aspect of our ability is to take in raw
sensor information through our eyes and
interpret it,
but it's just numbers.
That's something whether you're an
expert in computer vision person or new
to the field,
you have to always go back to meditate
on is what kind of things the machine is
given,
what,
what?
What is the data that is tasked to work
with in order to perform the task you're
asking it to do?
Perhaps the data is given is highly
insufficient to do what you wanted to
do.
That's the question I'll come up again
and again our images and enough to
understand the world around you and
given these numbers,
these set of numbers,
sometimes with one channel,
sometimes with three rgb where every
single have three different colors.
The task is to classify or regress
producing continuous variable or one of
a set of class labels as before,
we must be careful about our intuition
of what is hard,
what is easy and computer vision.
Let's take a step back to the
inspiration for an year old networks,
our own biological neural networks
because the human vision system and the
computer vision system is a little bit
more similar in these regards.
The structure of the human visual Cortex
is in layers and his information passes
from the eyes of the to the parts of the
brain that makes sense of the influence,
the raw sensor information hiring higher
order representations of formed.
This is the inspiration,
the idea behind using deep neural
networks for images higher and higher
order representation is a form for the
layers,
the early layers taking in the very raw
in sensory information that extracting
edges,
connecting those edges,
forming those edges to form more complex
features and finally into the higher
order semantic meaning that we hope to
get from these images and computer
vision.
Deep learning is hard.
I'll say this again.
The illumination variability is the
biggest challenge,
or at least one of the,
one of the biggest challenges in driving
for visible light cameras pose
variability.
The objects,
as I'll also discuss about some of the
advances from Geoff Hinton and the
capsule networks.
The idea with neural networks as they
are currently used for computer vision
are not good with representing variable
pose.
These objects in images and it's too
deep.
Plane of color and texture look very
different numerically when the object is
rotated and the object is mangled and
shaped in different ways.
The deformable will truncate a cat
interclass variability.
The classification task,
which would be an example today
throughout to introduce some of the
networks over the past decade that have
received success and some of the
intuition and insight that made those
networks work.
Classification,
there is a lot of variability inside the
classes and very little variability
between the classes.
All of these cats
at top,
all those are dogs a bottom.
They look very different and the other,
I would say the second biggest problem
in driving perception,
visible light camera perceptions,
occlusion when part of the object is
occluded due to the three dimensional
nature of our world,
some objects in front of others and they
occlude the background object.
And yet we're still tasked with
identifying the object when only part of
it is visible.
And sometimes that part I told you
there's cats is very hardly visible
here.
We're tasked with classifying a cat with
just an ears visible,
just the leg and on a philosophical
level as we'll talk about the motivation
for our competition here.
Here's a,
a,
a cat dressed as a monk,
eating a banana on a philosophical
level.
Most of us,
uh,
understand what's going on in the scene.
In fact,
a neural network to today successfully
classify this,
uh,
image this video as a cat,
but the context,
the humor of the situation,
and in fact you could argue it's a
monkey is missing.
And what else is missing is the dynamic
information,
the temporal dynamics of the scene.
That's what's missing in a lot of the
perception work that has been done to
date in the autonomous vehicle space,
uh,
in terms of visible light cameras and
we're looking to expand on that.
That's what segue.
Fuse is all about.
Image classification pipeline.
There's a been with different categories
inside each class.
Cat,
dog Mug,
hat,
those bins.
There's a lot of examples of each and
your task with when a new example comes
along you've never seen before to put
that image in a bin.
It's the same as the machine learning
task before and everything relies on the
data that has been ground truth,
that have been labeled by human beings.
Amnesty as a toy data set of handwritten
digits,
often using as examples and Coco psyfari
image net places,
and a lot of other incredible datasets.
Rich data sets of 100 thousands,
millions of images out there represent
scenes,
people's faces and different objects.
Those are all ground truth data for
testing algorithms and for competing
architectures to be evaluated against
each other.
Cfr Ten,
one of the simplest,
almost toy datasets of tiny with 10
categories of airplane,
automobile,
Bird,
cat,
deere,
dog,
frog,
course,
ship and truck is commonly used to
explore.
Some of the basic convolutional neural
networks will discuss,
so let's come up with a very trivial,
classify it to explain the concept of
how we could go about it.
In fact,
this is maybe if you start to think
about how to classify an image.
If you don't know any of these
techniques,
this is perhaps the approach you would
take is you would subtract images.
So in order to know that an image of a
cat is different than image of a dog,
you have to compare them when given
those two images,
what?
What's the what's the way you compare
them?
One way you could do it is you just
subtract it and then some all the pixel
wise differences in the image.
Just subtract the intensity of the image
pixel by Pixel.
Sum It up if that intent,
if that difference is really high,
that means the image is a very
different.
Using that metric,
we can look at cfr 10 and use it as a
classifier saying,
based on this difference function,
I'm going to find one of the 10 bins for
a new image that that is cool,
that has the lowest difference.
Find an image in this dataset that is
most like the image I have and put it in
the same bin.
Is that images in?
So there's 10 classes.
If we just flip a coin,
the accuracy of our classifier will be
10 percent.
Using our image difference classify,
we can actually do pretty good.
Much better than random was better than
10 percent.
We can do 35,
38 percent accuracy.
That's a classifier wherever first
classifier,
k nearest neighbors.
Let's take our classifier to a whole new
level instead of comparing it to just
fight.
Trying to find one image that's the
closest in our dataset.
We tried to find k closest and say what
is what class do the majority of them
belong to?
And we take that K and increase it for
one to two,
to three,
to four to five,
and see how that changes the problem
with seven years neighbors,
which is the optimal under this approach
for cfr 10,
we achieved 30 percent accuracy.
Human level is 95 percent accuracy and
convolutional neural networks will get
very close to a 100 percent.
That's were you on.
That works shine this very task of
binning images.
It all starts with this basic
computational unit signal in each of the
signals are wade summed,
bias added
and put an input into a nonlinear
activation function that produces an
output.
The nonlinear activation function is
key.
All of these put together and more and
more hidden layers form a deep neural
network,
and that deep neural network is trained
as we've discussed by taking a forward
pass on examples,
have ground truth labels.
Seeing how close those labels are too,
the real ground truth,
and then punishing the weights that
resulted in the incorrect decisions and
rewarding the weights that results in
incorrect decisions.
For the case of 10 examples,
the output of the network is 10
different values.
The input being handwritten digits from
zero to nine,
10 of those and one of our network to
classify what is in this image of a
handwritten digit is at one zero,
one,
two,
three through nine.
The way it's often done is there's 10
outputs of the network and each of the
neurons and the output is responsible
for getting really excited when it's
number is called and everybody else is
supposed to be not excited.
Therefore the number of classes is the
number of outputs.
That's how it's commonly done and you
assign a class to the input image based
on the highest,
the neuron which produces the highest
output,
but that's for a fully connected network
that we've discussed on Monday.
There is in deep learning a lot of
tricks that make things work that make
training much more efficient on large
class problems where there's a lot of
classes on large data sets.
When the representation that the neural
network is tasked with learning is
extremely complex and that's where
convolutional neural network step in
that trick.
They use a spatial invariance.
They use the idea that a cat in the top
left corner of an image is the same as a
cat in the bottom right corner of an
image,
so we can learn the same features across
the image.
That's where the convolution operation
steps in.
Instead of the fully connected networks
here,
there's a third dimension of depth,
so the blocks in this neural network
that as input take three d volumes in
this output produced three d volumes.
They take a slice of the image,
a window and it across applying this
same exact weights and we'll go through
an example,
the same exact weights as in the fully
connected network on the edges that are
used to map the input to the output.
Here are used to map the slice of an
image,
this window of an image to the output,
and you can make several,
many of such convolutional filters,
many layers,
many different options of what kind of
features do you look for in an image or
kind of window you slide across in order
to extract all kinds of things.
All kinds of edges,
all kinds of higher order patterns and
the images.
The very important thing is the
parameters on each of these filters,
these subset of the image,
these windows are shared.
If the feature,
the that defines a cat is useful in the
top left corner,
it's useful on the top right corner.
It's useful in every aspect of the
image.
This is the trick that makes
convolutional neural network save a lot
of a lot of parameters.
Reduced parameter significantly is the
reuse,
the spatial sharing of features across
the space of the image.
The depth of these three d volumes is
the number of filters.
The stride is the skip of the filter,
the step size,
how many pixels you skip when you apply
the filter to the input,
and the padding is the padding,
the zero padding on the outside of the
input to a convolutional layer.
Let's go through an example,
so on the left here and the slides are
available online.
You can follow them along and I'll step
through this example.
On the left here is input volume of
three channels.
The left column is the input.
The three blocks,
the three squares.
There are the three channels and there's
numbers inside those channels,
and then we have a filter in red,
two of them,
two channels of filters with a bias,
and we those filters are three by three.
Each one of them is size three by three,
and what we do is we take those three by
three filters that are to be learned.
These are variables are weights that
will have to learn,
and then we slide it across an image to
produce the output on the right,
the green,
so by applying the filters in the red,
there's two of them,
and within each one there's one for
every input channel,
we go from the left to the right,
from the input volume in the left to the
output volume green on the right,
and you can look at it.
You can pull up the slides yourself.
Now if you can't see the numbers on the
screen,
but the operations are performed on the
input to produce the single value that's
highlighted there in the green and the
output,
and we slide this convolution.
No filter along the image with the
stride in this case,
have to skipping,
skipping along.
They some to the to the right,
the two channel I'll put in green,
that's it.
That's the convolutional operation.
That's what's called a convolutional
layer neural networks and the parameters
here,
besides the bias of the red values in
the middle,
that's what we're trying to learn and
there's a lot of interesting tricks
we'll discuss today on top of those,
but this is at the core.
This is the specialty.
Invariant sharing of parameters that may
convolution you're on that works.
I'm able to efficiently learn and find
patterns and images to build your
intuition a little bit more about
convolution.
Here's an input image on the left and on
the right,
the identity filter produces the output
you see on the right,
and then there is different ways you
can,
different kinds of edges.
You can extract with the activate where
the resulting activation maps scene on
the right,
so when applying the filters,
those edge detection filters to the
image on the left you produce in white
are the parts that activate the
convolution.
The results of these filters,
and so you can do any kind of filter.
That's what we're trying to learn.
Any kind of edge,
any kind of any kind of pattern you can
move along in this window and this way
that's shown here.
You slide around the image and you
produce the output you see on the right
and depending on how many filters you
have in every level,
you have many of the slices,
the on the right,
the input on the left,
I'll put it on the right.
If you have dozens of filters,
you would have dozens of images on the
right,
each with different results that show
where each of the individual filter
patterns were found and we learn what
patterns are useful to look for in order
to perform the classification task.
That's the task for the neural network
to learn.
These filters and the filters have
higher and higher order of
representation.
Going from the very basic edges to the
high semantic meaning.
That spans entire images and the ability
to span images can be done in several
ways,
but traditionally has been successfully
done through Max pooling,
through pooling of taking the output of
a convolutional operation and reducing
the resolution of that by by condensing
that information,
but for example,
taking the maximum values,
the maximum activations,
therefore reducing the spatial
resolution which has detrimental effects
as we'll talk about in scene
segmentation,
but it's beneficial for finding higher
order representations and the images
that bring images together that bring
features together to form an entity that
we're trying to identify and classify.
Okay,
so that forms a convolution.
You'll networks such convolutional
layers stacked on top of each other is
the only addition to a neural network
that makes for a convolutional neural
network and then at the end the fully
connected layers or any kind of other
architectures allow us to apply
particular domains.
Let's take image net as a case study in
image net dataset and image net.
The challenge,
the task is classification.
As I mentioned,
the first lecture,
imaging as a data set,
one of the largest in the world of
images.
The $14 million images,
21,000
categories and a lot of depth to many of
the categories,
as I mentioned,
1200 granny Smith apples.
These allow to these allow them to learn
the rich representations in both posed
lighting variability and intercluster
class variation for the particular
things.
Particular classes like Granny Smith
apples,
so let's look through the various
networks.
Let's discuss them.
Let's see the insights.
It started with Alex Net,
the first really big successful GPU
train neural network on image net that's
achieved a significant boost over the
previous year and moved onto vgg net,
Google net,
a Goo lanette resonate yet cua image and
as ynet in 2017.
Again,
the numbers will show for the accuracy
or based on the top five error rate,
we get five guesses and it's a one or
zero.
If you get guests,
if one of the five is correct,
you get a one for that particular guest.
Otherwise it's a zero
and human error is five point one.
When a human tries to achieve the same
tries to perform the same task.
As the machinist asks,
we're doing the air is five point one,
the human adaptation that's performed on
the images based on binary
classification,
Granny Smith,
apple are not cat or not the actual task
that the machine has to perform and that
the human competing has to perform,
is given an image,
is provide one of the many classes under
that human error is five point one
percent,
which was surpassed in 2015 by residents
yet,
uh,
to achieve four percent error.
So let's start with Alex Net.
I'll zoom in on the later networks.
They have some interesting insights,
but Alex Net and Vgg net both followed a
very similar architecture,
very uniform throughout its depth.
Vgg Net in 2014 is convolution
convolution pooling,
and fully connected layers at the end
does a certain kind of beautiful
simplicity uniformity to these
architectures because you can just make
a deeper and deeper and makes it very
amenable to a implementation in the
layer stack kind of way.
And in any of the deep learning
frameworks,
it's clean and beautiful to understand.
In the case of egg net 16 or 19 layers
with 138 million parameters,
not many optimizations on these
parameters.
Therefore the number of parameters is
much higher than the networks that
followed it.
Despite the layers not being that large.
Google net introduced the inception
module,
starting to do some interesting things
with the small modules within these
networks which allow for the training to
be more efficient and effective.
The idea behind the inception module
shown here with the previous layer on
bottom and the convolutional layer here
with the inception module
on top producer on top is it used the
idea that different size convolutions
provide different value for the network.
Smaller convolutions are able to capture
or propagate forward features that are
very local in high resolution and in,
in,
in texture.
Larger convolutions are better able to
to represent and capture and catch
highly abstracted features,
higher order features.
So the idea behind the inception module
is to say,
well,
as opposed to choosing an in a hyper
parameter tuning process or architecture
design process,
choosing which convolution size we want
to go with,
why not do all of them?
To get well several together in the case
of the Google net model,
there's the one by one,
three by three and five by five
convolutions with the old trusty friend
of Max pooling still left in there as
well,
which has lost favor more and more over
time for the image classification task,
and the result is there's fewer
parameters are required.
If you pick the placing of these
inception modules correctly,
the number of parameters required to
achieve a higher performance is much
lower
radnet,
one of the most popular still to date
architectures that we'll discuss in and
scene segmentation as well came up and
use the idea of a residual block.
The initial inspiring observation,
which doesn't necessarily hold true as
it turns out,
but that network depth increases
representation power,
so these residual blocks allow you to
have much deeper networks,
and I'll explain why in a second here,
but the thought was they worked so well
because the networks how much deeper.
The key thing that makes these blocks so
effective is the same idea.
It's very reminiscent of recurrent
neural networks that I hope we get a
chance to talk about the training of
them as much easier.
They will take a simple block repeated
over and over,
and they passed the input along with our
transformation along with the ability to
transform and to learn to learn the
filters,
learn the weights so you're allowed to.
You're allowed every layer to not only
take on the processing of previous
layers,
but to take in the wrong transform data
and learn something new.
The ability to learn something new
allows you to have much deeper networks
and the simplicity of this block allows
for more effective training.
These state of the art in 2017,
the winner is squeezing excitation
networks.
That unlike the previous year was cu
image with shimply took ensemble methods
and combined a lot of successful
approaches to take a marginal
improvement as seen.
Net got a significant improvement,
at least in percentages,
I think as a 25 percent reduction in
error
from four percent to three percent.
Something like that.
By using a very simple idea that I think
is important to mention as simple
insight.
It added a parameter to each channel and
the convolutional layer and the
convolutional block,
so the network can now adjust the
weighting and each channel based for for
each feature map,
based on the content,
based on the input to the network.
This is kind of a takeaway to think
about about any of the networks who talk
about any of the architectures is a lot
of times you were recurrent neural
networks and convolution neural networks
have tricks that significantly reduced
the number of parameters,
the bulk,
the sort of low hanging fruit.
They use spatial invariants of temporal
and to reduce the number of parameters
to represent the input data,
but they also lead certain things not
parametrized.
They don't allow the network to learn
it.
Allowing this case to network to learn
the waiting on each of the individual
channels.
So each of the individual filters is
something that you learn as a long with
the filters takes.
It makes a huge boost.
The cool thing about this is it's
applicable to any architecture.
This kind of block,
this kind of what the squeeze and
excitation block is applicable to any
architecture.
And,
uh,
because obviously it's a,
it's just simply a parametrized is the
ability to choose which filter you go
with based on the content.
It's a subtle but crucial thing I think
is pretty cool.
And for future research it inspires to
think about,
uh,
what else can be parametrized and neural
networks,
what else can be controlled as part of
the learning process,
including hiring higher order hyper
parameters,
which,
which aspects of the training and the
architecture of the network can be part
of the learning.
This is what this network inspires.
Another network has been in development
since the nineties ideas but Jeff
Hinton,
but really received,
has been published on received
significant attention,
2017 that I won't go into detail here.
Uh,
we are going to release an online only
video about capsule networks.
It's a little bit too technical,
but they inspire very important point
that we should always think about deep
learning.
Uh,
whenever it's successful is to think
about what,
as I mentioned with the cat eating a
banana on a philosophical and the
mathematical level,
we have to consider what assumptions
these networks make and what through
those assumptions they throw away.
So neural networks due to the spacial
with convolutional neural networks due
to their spatial invariance throwaway
information about the relationship
between the hierarchies between the
simple and the complex objects.
So the face on the left and the face on
the right looks the same to accomplish
in neural network.
The presence of eyes and nose and mouth
is the essential aspect of what makes
the classification task work for
accomplished or network.
It will what worry will fire and say
this is definitely a face,
but the spatial relationship is lost,
is ignored.
Which means there's a lot of
implications to this.
But for things like pose variation,
that information is lost.
We're throwing away that away completely
and hoping that the pooling operation
that's performing these networks is able
to sort of Mesh everything together to
come up with the features that are
firing of the different parts of the
face.
That then come up with a total
classification that is a face without
representing really the relationship
between these features at the low level
and the high level at the low level of
the hierarchy,
the simple and the complex level.
This is super exciting field now that's
hopefully will spark developments of how
we design your networks that are able to
learn this,
the rotational,
the orientation and variance a as well.
Okay,
so as I mentioned,
you take these convolutional neural
networks,
chop off the final layer in order to
apply to a particular domain,
and that is what we'll do with fully
convolutional neural networks.
The ones that we tasked to segment the
image at a pixel level.
As a reminder,
these networks through the convolutional
process are really producing a heat map,
different parts of the network and
getting excited based on the different
aspects of the image and so it can be
used to do the localization of
detecting,
not just classifying the image but
localized in the object.
And it could do so at a pixel level.
So the convolutional layers are doing
the encoding process.
They're taking the rich raw sensory
information in the image and encoding
them into
an interpretable set of features,
a representation that can then be used
for classification,
but we can also then use a decoder up
sample that information and produce a
map like this fully convolution neural
network segmentation,
semantic segmentation,
image segmentation.
The goal is to,
as opposed to classify the entire image,
it can classify every single pixel,
this pixel level segmentation you call
her every single pixel with what that
Pixel,
what object that pixel belongs to in
this two d space of the image,
the two d projection,
the,
uh,
in the image of a three dimensional
world.
So the thing is,
there's been a lot of advancement in the
last three years,
but it's still an incredibly difficult
problem if you think,
if you think about,
uh,
the amount of data that's used for
training and the task of Pixel level,
uh,
of megapixels here of millions of pixels
that are tasked with having a,
a single label,
it's an extremely difficult problem.
Why is this interesting,
important problems to try to solve as
opposed to Bonnie boxes around cats?
Well,
it's whenever precise boundaries of
objects are important.
Certainly medical applications when
looking at imaging and detecting
particular,
for example,
detecting tumors and,
uh,
in,
in medical imaging of,
of different,
uh,
different organs
and in driving and robotics,
when objects are involved as a dense
scene of all the vehicles,
pedestrians,
cyclists,
we need to be able to not just have a
loose estimate of where objects are.
We need to be able to have the exact
boundaries and then potentially through
data fusion,
fusing sensors together,
fusing this rich textual information
about pedestrians,
cyclists,
and vehicles to light our data that's
providing us the three dimensional map
of the world or have both these semantic
meaning of the different objects and
their exact three mentioned location.
Um,
a lot of this work successfully,
a lot of the work and the semantic
segmentation started with fully
convolutional networks for semantic
segmentation,
paper,
fcn.
That's where the name fcn came from in
November 2014.
Now go through a few papers here to give
you some intuition where the field has
gone and how that takes us to segue
views,
the segmentation competition.
So fcn,
repurpose the image,
net pretreating nets the nets that were
trained to classify what's in an image,
entire image,
and chopped off the fully connected
layers.
And then have added decoder parts that
up,
sample the image to produce a heat map
here,
showing a,
uh,
with a tabby cat,
a heat map of where the cat is in the
image.
It's a much slower,
much coarser resolution than the input
image
one eighth at best.
Skip connections to improve courses of
upsampling.
There's a few tricks.
If you do the most naive approach,
the upsampling is going to be extremely
course because that's the whole point of
the neural network.
The encoding part is you throw away all
the useless data,
uh,
the,
you to the most essential aspects that
represent that image.
So you're throwing away a lot of
information that's necessary to then
form a high resolution image.
So there's a few tricks where you skip a
few of the final pooling operations to
go in a similar way.
And this is the residual block to a go
to go to the output produced higher and
higher resolution heat map at the end
segment in 2015.
I applied this to the driving context
and really taking it to Kitty Dataset
and have have have shown a lot of
interesting results and really explored
the encoder decoder or formulation of
the problem.
Really solidifying this the place of the
encoder decoder framework for the
segmentation task dilated convolution.
I'm taking you through a few components
which are critical here to the state of
the art dilated convolutions,
so the convolution operation as the
pooling operation reduces resolution
significantly and dilated convolution
has a certain kind of gritting as
visualized there that maintains the the
local high resolution textures while
still capturing the spatial window
necessary.
It's called dilated convolutional layer
and that's in a 2015 paper,
proved to be much better at upsampling.
A high resolution image.
The lab with a B v One v Two v three
added conditional random fields,
which is the final piece of the of the
state of the art puzzle here.
A lot of the successful networks today
that do segmentation,
not all do post process using a crs
conditional random fields,
and what they do is they smoothed the
segmentation,
the ups sampled segmentation that
results from the fcn by looking at the
underlying image intensities.
So that's the key aspects of the
successful approaches.
Today.
You have the encoder decoder framework
of a fully accomplished in your network.
It replaces the fully connected layers
with a convolutional layers,
dee dee convolutional layers,
and as the years progressed from 2014 to
today as usual,
the underlying networks from Alex Net to
Vgg net and to now Raza net have been
one of the big reasons for the
improvements of these networks to be
able to perform the segmentation.
So naturally they mirrored the image,
net challenge performance and adapting
these networks.
So the state of the art uses resonate or
similar networks conditional random
fields for smoothing based on the input
image intensities and the dilated
convolution that maintains the
computational cost,
but increases the resolution of the
upsampling throughout the intermediate
feature maps.
And that takes us to the state of the
art that we used to produce the images
to produce the images for the
competition.
Brezhnev do you see for dance upsampling
convolution instead of by linear
upsampling,
you make the upsampling learnable.
You learned the upscaling filters that's
on the bottom.
That's really the key part that made it
work.
There should be a theme here.
Sometimes the biggest addition,
they can be done.
This parametrizing one of the aspects of
the network that you've taken for
granted.
Letting the network learn that aspect
and the other.
I'm not sure how important it is to the
success,
but it's a.
it's a cool little addition,
is a hybrid dilated convolution.
As I showed that visualization where the
convolution is spread apart a little bit
at in the input from the input to the
output,
the steps of that dilated convolution
filter,
when they are changed,
it produces a smoother results because
when it's kept the same,
are there certain input?
Pixels get a lot more attention than
others,
so losing that favoritism as well.
It's achieved by using a variable
difference dilation rate.
Those are the two tricks,
but really the biggest one is the
parametric,
one of the upscaling filters.
Okay,
so that's what we're.
That's what we use to generate that data
and that's we provide you the code with
if you're interested in competing in
psych fuse.
The other aspect here that everything
we've talked about,
ball from the classification to the
segmentation to making sense of images
is there the information about a time
the temporal dynamics of the scene is
thrown away and for the driving context
of the robotics contests and what we'd
like to do is take fuse for the
segmentation dynamic scene segmentation
context of when you try to interpret
what's going on in and seen over time
and use that information.
Time is essential.
The the movement of pixels is essential
through time.
That that understanding how those
objects move in a three d space through
the two d projection of an image is
fascinating and there's a lot of set of
open problems there.
So flow is what's very helpful too as a
starting point to help us understand how
these pixels move flow,
optical flow,
dance optical computation that are best
at our best approximation of where each
pixel in image one
and moved in temporarily following
image.
After that,
there's two images in 30 frames.
A second is one image at time zero,
the other is 33 point three milliseconds
later,
and the dense optical flow is our best
estimate of how each pixel in the input
image moved to end.
The output image and the optical flow
for every pixel produces a direction of
where we think that pixel moved and the
magnitude of how far moved that allows
us to take information that we detected
about the first frame and try to
propagate it forward.
This is the competition is to try to
segment and image and propagate that
information forward for manual
annotation of a of an image.
So this kind of coloring book
annotation,
will you call every single pixel in the
state of the art data set for driving
city scapes that it takes one point
five,
one point five hours,
90 minutes to do that coloring,
that's 90 minutes per image.
That's extremely long time.
That's why it doesn't exist today.
Dataset.
And in this class we're going to create
one
of segmentation of these images is
through time,
through video,
so long videos where every single frame
is fully segmented.
That's still an open problem that we
need to solve flows,
a piece of that.
And we also provide you the this
computer state of the art flow using
flow net two point.
Oh,
so flow net one point,
oh,
in May 2015,
use neural networks to learn the optical
flow,
the dense optical flow.
And it did so with two kinds of
architectures.
Flow net s flown out,
simple and flown on.
Core flow in that.
See the simple one is simply taking the
two images.
So what's,
what's the task here?
There's two images and you want to
produce in those two images,
they follow each other in time,
33 point three milliseconds apart,
and uh,
your task is the Zl output to produce
the dense optical flow.
So for the simple architecture,
you just stack them together,
each our rgb,
so it produces a six channel input to
the network.
There's a lot of convolution and finally
it's the same kind of process as the
fully convolutional neural networks to
produce the optical flow.
Then there is flown at correlation
architecture where you performed some
convolutions separately before using a
correlation later to combine the feature
maps.
Both are effective and different
datasets and different applications.
So flow net two point zero in December
2016 is one of the state of the art
frameworks code bases that we use to
generate the data.
I'll show combines the flown at sm,
flown as C and improves over the initial
flow net.
Producing a smoother flow field
preserves the fine motion detail along
the edges of the objects and it runs
extremely efficiently depending on the
architecture as a few variants,
either eight to 140 frames a second,
and the process there is essentially one
that's common across various
applications.
Deep learning is stacking these networks
together.
The very interesting aspect here that
we're still exploring,
and again applicable in all of deep
learning in this case,
it seemed that there was a strong effect
in taking sparse small,
multiple Dataset and doing the training,
the order of which those datasets were
used for the training process mattered a
lot.
That's very interesting.
So using flow net two point zero,
here's the Dataset we're making
available for psych fuse.
The competition cars that mit did,
you use less sex views first.
The original video,
US driving in high definition 10 ADP and
a eightK ,
three 60 video
original video driving around a
cambridge.
Then we're providing the ground truth
for a training set for that training set
for every single frame.
30 frames a second,
we're providing the segmentation frame
to frame to frame segmented on
mechanical Turk.
We're also providing the output of the
network that I mentioned,
the dad,
there are segmentation network that's
pretty damn close to the ground truth,
but still not.
And our task is.
This is the interesting thing is our
task is to take the output of this
network.
Well there's two options.
One is to take the output of this
network and use CA use other networks to
help you propagate the information
better.
So what this segmentation,
the output of this network does is it
only takes a frame by frame by frame.
It's not using the temporal information
at all.
So the question is can we figure out a
way,
can we figure out tricks to use temporal
information to improve this
segmentation?
So it looks more like this segmentation
and we're also providing the optical
flow from frame to frame to frame.
So the optical flow based on flown at
two point zero of how each of the pixels
moved.
Okay.
And now forms the psych fuse
competition.
10,000
images.
And the task is to submit code.
We have starter code in python and on
good hub to take in the original video,
take in for the training,
set the ground truth,
the segmentation from the state of the
art segmentation network,
the optical flow from the state of the
art optical flow network,
and taking that together to improve the.
The stuff on the bottom left,
the segmentation to try to achieve the
ground truth on the on the top right.
Okay.
With that,
I'd like to thank you.
Tomorrow at one PM is Waymo in data 32,
one,
two,
three.
The next lecture,
next week we'll be on deep learning for
a sensing the human understanding the
human,
and we will release online only lecture
on capsule networks and Gans generative
adversarial networks.
Thank you very much.